bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur ft france ce soir alors cette
visite donc du premier ministre français
reporter qui devait se dérouler donc
demain alger elle est reportée cinédit
officiellement pour des causes
sanitaires on est d'accord ce n'est
probablement pas la véritable raison
quelles sont les raisons véritables de
ce report selon vous rémi tales mais je
crois que les relations se sont tendues
depuis quelques mois entre la france et
l'algérie et pourtant la france avait
tout fait pour recevoir les bonnes
grâces du pouvoir algérien puisqu'elle
est à plat ventre
depuis plusieurs mois maintenant
présentant ses excuses allons rendre un
hommage je cite au martyre du fln et ça
n'a pas suffi ça n'a pas suffit parce
que la stratégie du gouvernement
algérien c'est de se défausser tout
simplement sur notre pays et de reporter
son inaction au plan interne sur le
passé commun qui nous lie avec l'algérie
je crois que le peuple algérien mérite
mieux que cela
gama la vina vous êtes d'accord là la
france est à plat ventre face justement
au pouvoir algérien n'a absolument pas
mais je réponde à la question là pour la
question à savoir pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
n'ont pas n'ont pas satisfait la demande
de castex devenir ce qu'il est venu avec
quatre ministres alors qu'il était prévu
qu'il vienne tout de même avec je me
disais administre avec les savoirs et
chose deuxième chose c'est pas la pl
ventrisme qu'il ya des relations qui
sont quand même très tendues depuis 60
ans et pas des relations qui sont liés
seulement à des problèmes internes en
algérie depuis chirac c'est pas des
relations soyez seulement un passé
colonial qui s'est bien passé ça n'est
pas des relations qui sont liés
seulement à l'idée par exemple que la
france deux jours avant d'ailleurs
l'algérie reconnaît là où loeb la
possession a ouvert une ambassade sahara
occidental toutes ces raisons là sont
des provocations a minima mais au delà
de ça c'est surtout des relations
délétères en matière d'investissement
ces relations délétères matière de
passer et d'une négation du passé il
faut tout neuf de rappeler que l'algérie
entre l'entrée de la france en algérie
et sa sortie on estime qu' entre 3 et 5
millions de personnes qui ont été tuées
et 30 % la population en 1830 et ils en
sortent
on estime entre eux trois cent mille
pour les français et un million cinq
cent mille
j'ai rien pour les algériens mais on ne
peut pas réduire ça à de l'appelant
d'entrisme cia mais de la peur en prise
il ya longtemps que la france aurait
reconnu ses crimes
départs dont ceux qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui oui parce que dans le
rapport aux stora de benjamin stora
l'historien les recommandations
mémorielle il n'y a pas d' excuses pour
l'instant minitel il ya eu des gestes
d'ouverture de l'apparat du président
emmanuel macron n'y a pas d'excusé
surtout de la part de l'algérie et
monsieur parle des morts algériens
j'aimerais aussi qu'on parle des pieds
noirs qui sont morts des 50 milliards
qui ont été massacrés par le fln et
puisque vous faites un devoir
d'inventaire sur les noirs on apprend il
ya quelques jours que les moines de
tibérine vous savez ces moines qui avait
été enlevé et puis assassinée aurait été
en fait assassiner par le pouvoir
algérien qui avait tenté de mettre ça
sur le dos du gia à des fins politiques
et la france devrait demander des
comptes à l'algérie donc vous savez si
on fait le bilan après 60 années
d'indépendance je crois que l'algérie a
tout autant à se reprocher que la france
n'a pu avoir se reprocher durant la
période de la colonisation
sur le volet économique on ne peut pas
d'un côté accusé la france de
néo-colonialisme et de l'autre tout
attendre du gouvernement français pour
le dit la dynamisation de l'économie
algérienne
l'économie algérienne est riche de son
sol elle a tout à fait le pouvoir enfin
le gouvernement a le pouvoir de faire
bénéficier à la population des fruits de
cette richesse il a choisi de ne pas le
faire c'est sa responsabilité
ce n'est pas la responsabilité de la
france et cela donne niveau nos qui vont
pouvoir changer cela on va répondre à sa
question économique très rapidement
quand on se moque des algériens qu'on
prétend qu'on investit en l'algérie une
usine renault qui n'a pas tenu ses
engagements qui peut faire 40 % de taux
d'intégration qui n'aime pas rester à 5%
alors que c'était contractuels on se
moque des algériens quand on envoie une
des usines de montage en cascade juste
pour vendre des kits en algérie ça c'est
pas de l'exploitation et du
néocolonialisme et ensuite vous avez
tort de dire que l'algérie compte sur la
france c'est faux
la chine travaille que l'algérie
d'allemagne su non c'est faux la chine
travaille que l'algérie l'allemagne le
seul problème entre l'algérie la france
qui a 6 millions à peu près l'estimé
d'algériens qui sont d'ici et je
rappelle tout de même pour ce qui
concerne les questions économiques
que la france dépend autant l'algérie
que le vice et versa je vais pas vous
raconter le rapport avec areva total
avec le pétrole avec bouygues pourra pas
les succès des successions de déchets
qu'économique en investissements
français en algérie se multiplient dans
des conditions extraordinaires mais j'en
ai vous dire un truc sincèrement par
rapport à la question c'est pas grand
chose pour vous cent trente deux ans
cotisations alors ça fait des années je
suis français d'origine algérienne qu'on
ne saoule avec les quatre ans de
colonisation allemande en france ça
c'était grave
alors que le nombre de morts n'est pas
comparable là on peut pleurer pendant
des siècles sur les crimes allemand et
il a fallu du temps pour que l'allemagne
qui demande pardon tout de suite à la
france soit pardonné alors que les
français qui ont cent vingt-huit ans de
plus de cotisations barbare je rappelle
tout de même qu'en moyenne il y avait à
peu près une vraie loi tous les dix ans
et des milliers de morts à chaque fois
qu'ils avaient pendant les gars
l'algérie entre 300 et 600 morts par
semaine
vous parlez des fid et des pieds noirs
qui ont participé à ces massacres
je vous rappelle tout de même assez
négatif qu'il faut pas sympa l'été loire
des harkis on est très précis qui ont
participé à ces massacres
je vous rappelle que c'est bio dillon
l'algérie contrôler un pied noir aux
harkis c'est superbe
on a des esclaves qu'ils font pousser
les oranje qu'on en compte dans la pile
le soleil on a des escarres qu'on peut
frapper et écraser réduire à la halla
halla halla la misère sociale
intellectuelle germes et y avait parlé
d'un peuple à l'époque tels qu'ils
étaient au début colonialiste avait dit
quand elle est ailleurs l'algérie within
ce climat très important jamais tillon
avec une chose essentielle elle a dit
qu'on a clochardisé appup aucune
cotisation monde n'est arrivé à ceux de
négation de l'humanité à ce point à
telle enseigne que mon père par exemple
avait interdiction d'aller à l'école et
tous ses frères et soeurs ça c'est les
choses que vous ne racontez pas voulait
réagir à répondre un rémy très
rapidement il ya évidemment une douleur
de se passer et le pas tout noir ou tout
blanc c'est très clair enfin je note
quand même que comme vous le dites
vous-même d'ailleurs depuis on assigne
en algérie en france donc que ils
doivent pas garder un si mauvais
souvenir de la france que ça et puis moi
je vous le dit non mais je vous le dis
très tranquillement moi j'invite tous
ceux qui considèrent que la france est
le plus grand collectionneur sur terre
de crimes contre l'humanité et bien
acquitté ce ping puisqu'il leur est
insupportable dans qu'il le quitte
et puis qu'ils aillent ailleurs pas
forcément des jelly mais dans des pays
on pourrait les accueillir ya un
paradoxe si vous
ce disque on va juste avant ses dents
dans le débat juste pour revenir sur un
point que vous avez évoqué tout à leurs
gammes à la vina il s'agit justement de
l'ouverture par al la république en
marche d'un bureau à dakhla sous
contrôle marocain faisant partie du
territoire revendiqué par le front
polisario on sait que la question du
sahara occidental une question très
sensible et cette décision finalement
elle est très bien perçu on comprend du
côté marocain et ans elle est perçue
comme une provocation du côté algérien
c'est quoi c'est une maladresse au sein
de la majorité présidentielle vous
pensez ou alors la france elle joue un
rôle trouble alors je vais très clair
sur le gouvernement français d'abord
pour répondre très rapidement
non les algériens de france n'ont pas de
problème avec les français ils ont un
problème avec la politique française et
vous mélanger les deux moi j'ai un
problème qui la politique algérienne
pendant des années particulièrement 90
presse qui a été tenue avec la sq ont
appelé la promotion la cause dont des
généraux fin des anciens caporaux de
l'armée française qui ont participé au
massacre
vous avez parlé de tibéri qui viennent
tout à l'heure c'est très bien mais ça
fait partie de l'émanation de ce qui
restait de la france à l'algérie six
femmes et caporaux qui ont pris le
pouvoir
on est sa cote est maintenant concernant
le jeu trouble il est pas si trouble
monsieur macron et pour le rapprochement
entre la france et l'algérie et monsieur
tebboune a rappelé que macro et le
meilleur interlocuteur
on a eu entre en 60 ans et pour cause il
n'a pas connu la guerre n'est pas n'est
pas fils de colon il n'a pas tout ce
passé un petit peu rance et certains ont
travaillé pendant les amis et
malheureusement dans son dans sa
majorité puisque cette une
un groupement c'est un peu comme le
front national c'est un groupement de
partis qui s'est constituée autour de la
force la personne de monsieur macron
malheureusement il ya des gens très à
droite qui sont contre ce rapprochement
et qui ont des gestes de provocation
c'est le parlement qui l'a fait pas
monsieur mâcon qui a obtenu ce bureau
inter l'a d'ailleurs c'est sa
bureautique illégale aux yeux l'oeil nu
mais je rentre pas là-dedans limite ça
m'intéresse pas parce que je vous
rapprochement entre le maroc et algérie
mais il se doit il se trouve que les
jeux troubles de la france par rapport
au maroc et l'algérie il se joue là au
lieu de calmer les tensions et d'essayer
de jouer la came d'hyères créer des
conditions de paix qu honorable entre
ces deux pays et l'histoire de sa
réaction talent
on y met un petit peu de 2,2 de feu on
oublie par exemple les essais nucléaires
français doivent être effectivement
c'est un crime n'a encore doivent être
réparés par ceux qui l'ont fait les
français 3 essais à ciel ouvert je vous
pose une question simplement puisque la
douleur on parle de lure en moi je parle
de mort j'ai eu un tiers de ma famille
qui est éliminé en cinq heures à thiers
et je n'ai pas les données des français
vous trompez
la haine d'une politique néocolonialiste
des serveurs dirigeants français qui ne
sont pas tous comme ça quand on met
trois bombes atomiques dans les impôts
quand on a pas fait du côté du larzac
pourquoi ne pas essayer ça ici
puisqu'ils n'étaient pas très grave moi
j'aurais aimé ça il faut un petit peu
plus éclairés sur ces questions là et ne
pas sortir ces lieux communs qui
consiste à réduire laisser coloniale
comme une sorte formidable chose qui a
existé historiquement alors qu elle
était c'est une catastrophe humaine
personne ne dit ça et moi non plus les
essais nucléaires malheureusement se
sont pas limitées ou sahara algérien nos
compatriotes d'outre-mer s'en
souviennent mais moi j'appelle à la
cohérence j'appelle à la coi devant je
pense que le l'intérêt aujourd'hui de la
france comme celui de l'algérie c'est de
réconcilier nos mémoires mais pour
réconcilier les mémoires il faut être
deux et aujourd'hui la volonté elle est
que d'un côté et moi je j'en veux aussi
beaucoup au gouvernement français de sa
naïveté dans le choix de ses
interlocuteurs et dans l'idée que il
suffirait de encore une fois je le dis
de s'agenouiller y compris devant des
criminels parce que ce qu'on appelle les
martyrs du fln sont des criminels et
gérald darmanin et et s'agenouiller
devant les criminels du fln
bien sûr ben oui en novembre 2000 jean
vous vérifierez non ceux qui défendront
les nude elle sait les agresseurs qui
sont les criminels quand on n'est pas
chez soi qu'on va tuer des femmes des
enfants violés romas le criminel il est
clair quand les nazis arrivée en france
vous disais pas que les résistants
français ce sont les criminels vous
écouter à vous écouter messieurs on a le
sentiment quand même un peu plus
emmanuel macron tentent justement des
gestes d'apaisement pourra mettre fin
c'est année tumultueuse dans les
relations entre l'algérie et la france
est bien plus ça devient difficile et ça
se solde finalement par un échec ça se
complique pour une raison c'est que
comme la com com la france ne se
respectent pas elle-même elle ne peut
pas être respecté ses interlocuteurs
internationaux c'est vrai pour l'algérie
c'est vrai on l'a vu avec monsieur
erdogan et le ski a été fait
européenne on ne peut pas exiger le
respect des autres
quand on a pas du respect pour son
propre pays pour son jeu sa propre
histoire là je comprends pas vous mettez
un air de ganay l'algérie sur le même
plan ça n'a rien à voir
ensuite la france est une grande
puissance qui est quand même une
puissance nucléaire donc n'aurait pas de
respect elle se respecte
avec ses intérêts bien compris c'est
qu'elle a de l'argent à ses aventures
tips pourparlers la turquie mais ça n'a
rien à voir
elle sait qu'elle l'a rejoint sur
l'algérie sans collaboration sérieuse
moi je vous parle d'une chose simplement
je vais donner un message qui est très
clair monsieur mâcon s'il m'entend et à
vous qui semblez ne pas le comprendre
si la france veut que ça se passe bien
l'afrique du nord elle a besoin du poids
économique et la puissance militaire et
impuissance humaine 45 millions
personnes en algérie en co développement
en colocalisation ça m'était proposé à
l'époque de du temps du jeu des
socialistes
la colocalisation ça consiste à faire
quoi ça consiste à faire 1 puis 5 2 3 ça
pas de la synergie créée des conditions
économiques fortes pour faire en sorte
que l'algérie se développe dans un
premier temps en collaboration gagnant
gagnant et puis ensuite espérer colosse
de l'afrique en bénéficient mais où vous
êtes en forme
est ce que la france elle doit elle doit
pas ce qu'on voit qu'il ya des
déclarations que ça avec les esprits
s'échauffent un puisqu'à le ministre du
travail de la sécurité sociale en
algérie qui a qualifié la france d'
ennemi traditionnel éternelle lors d'une
allocution ça fait suite à l'ouverture
d'un bureau à dakhla par la république
en marche mais vous parlais tout à
l'heure des moines de tibérine il ya
quand même eu un rapport il ya un procès
aussi est ce qu'il faudrait pas aussi
que la france elle s'excuse une bonne
fois pour toutes par rapport à son passé
colonial et voilà et ça m est peut-être
un terme justement à haute tension mais
si on met le passé sur la table il faut
mettre tout le passé sur la table et pas
une partie seulement celle qui nous est
celle qui nous arrange je suis désolé
monsieur mais vous n'avez que le mot de
néocolonialisme à la bouche et en même
temps vous apprends rien du tout
elles deux la france sur le
développement économique de l'algérie
mais l'algérie si elle veut se
développer économiquement il faut
qu'elle compte sur ses gouvernants et
que les peuples le peuple algérien s'est
d'ailleurs je crois ce qu'il est en
train de faire travail à une évolution
du régime en algérie
du reste je me permets quand même cette
petite remarque sur le
le la boutade du ministre de sécurité
sociale algérien auquel j'ai envie de
répondre que quand il s'agit de sécurité
sociale tous les algériens le considère
à la france comme l'ennemi éternel
je pense qu'on va l'être activité notre
pays mais bien sûr mais bien sûr si elle
est bien sûr vous voulez qu'on ferme et
bien sûr va faire notre jeu réponde à ça
parce que c'est grave je sais pas si
vous êtes au fn mais apparemment vous
n'êtes pas vous n'avez pas un bon
logiciel une petite fille que sur les
côtés ministre comme vous ça c'est
certain
non c'est pas leur petit modèle liste si
je suis ici je suis criirad messieurs
s'il vous plaît je suis juste là même
temps et on conclut s'il vous plaît
merci d'écouter la france que je vais
vous n'avez pas voulais pas me donner de
son monsieur maintenant je vous
expliquais un truc simplement l'algérie
donne cent mille euros pour lancer des
investissements à titre individuel en
france
matt en parlant des français puisque
voulait par le système social qui est
une magnifique apparemment en france
pour obtenir un crédit jeu par la france
et européens comme vous d'accord il est
obligé passer par une association
s'appelle la ville obligés de passer par
des systèmes de travers pour espérer
avoir le minimum syndical alors le coup
des allocations familiales soit on
arrête c'est du front national merci
merci merci je rappelle que vous êtes co
fondateur du mouvement des droits
civiques merci également à vous un rémi
tales analyste politique fondateur de
marianne conseil